their arrest was dramatic and so is the
story to Americans among a group of
mercenaries caught in an alleged failed
coup attempt in Venezuela dragged from a
fishing boat forced to lie on the ground
at gunpoint
now Venezuelan state TV was broadcasting
their apparent plan to remove president
Nicolas Maduro mr. midori quickly
claimed president Trump was the master
his administration and from wydo
Venezuela's opposition leader denied any
involvement
there's no US government direct
involvement in this operation
we'd have been involved it would have
gone differently as for who bankrolled
that we're not prepared to share any
more information about what we know took
place president madurai took great
delight in sharing the men's identity
documents not even the the narrow the
random in louis in torch and design
texas impressive silver
applauded the fishermen and women who
cook we manage risk
anywhere anytime
any situation the two men worked for a
florida-based security company silver
caught its director confirmed they were
on a mission to capture Venezuela's
leader their operations sank before it
sailed the US government now says it
will use every tool to secure their
attack cordelia let Sky News Washington